JACQUI: CONGRESSMAN RICK
CRAWFORD, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SATURDAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GRIFF.
GRIFF: WE’RE JOINED BY THE
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING A SATURDAY AND ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE SAME COMMITTEE,
TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE, JUST THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE.
SO LET ME JUST PICK UP WHERE
CONGRESSMAN CRAWFORD LEFT OFF
SAYING THAT SPEAKER PELOSI
COULD BE HOLDING THIS ALL
HOSTAGE AS THE SENATE RIGHT NOW
AS WE SPEAK WORKING ON THE
LEGISLATION, WORKING ON THE
BILL FOR THE $1.2 TRILLION
ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL, BUT
YET, SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS THAT
SHE WON’T TAKE UP ANYTHING
UNTIL BOTH PIECES ARE SENT
OVER, PASSED IN THE SENATE,
THAT BEING THE $31/2 TRILLION
BUDGET RECONCILIATION.
IS THIS, CONGRESSMAN, IN
TROUBLE?
WHERE DO THINGS STAND AS FAR AS
YOU SEE IT IN THE HOUSE CAUCUS?
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU.
DEMOCRATS AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
PUT A DOWN PAYMENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN SENDING
$350 BILLION TO STATES AND
CITIES FOR WATER AND COVID
RECOVERY AND WE’RE GOING TO
FINISH WITH THIS BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THERE’S LOTS OF ZIGS AND ZAGS
AHEAD OF US, AND, BUT WE’LL
ENSURE CLEAN WATER FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION, AND HIGH SPEED
INTERNET, AND WE’RE GOING TO
MAKE THE AMERICAN WORKER THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE IN THE WORLD.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, IF YOU
WILL, WE HAVE THIS RARE LIVE
SENATE SESSION, YOU HAVE THE
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN
TALKING NOW ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
SHE HAS COME TO TALK NOT ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT EVICTIONS.
LET’S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> BEHIND ON RENTAL PAYMENTS.
LAST YEAR CONGRESS WORKED
TOGETHER TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT
STAGGERING REALITY.
WE PROVIDED MORE THAN $45
BILLION IN EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE, THAT MONEY IS NOW
FINALLY GETTING INTO THE HANDS
OF LANDLORDS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
IT’S HELPING FAMILIES WHO LOST
JOBS GET CAUGHT UP ON THEIR
MISSED PAYMENTS.
BUT THE MONEY IS GETTING OUT
TOO SLOWLY.
SOME STATES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OPENED THEIR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ONLY LAST
MONTH.
SOME HAVEN’T SPENT A SINGLE
DOLLAR BY THE BEGINNING OF
JUNE.
NOW THAT’S STARTING TO CHANGE.
IN JUNE STATES DELIVERED MORE
THAN $11/2 BILLION IN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
THAT MONEY WENT TO HELP NEARLY
300,000 HOUSEHOLDS.
BUT THERE ARE STILL BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO DISTRIBUTE AND
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES IN NEED.
WE HAVE THE TOOLS AND WE HAVE
THE FUNDING.
WHAT WE NEED IS THE TIME.
LOOK, I AGREE THAT THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM IS NOT A LONG-TERM
SOLUTION, BUT LET ME BE VERY
CLEAR, IT IS THE RIGHT
SHORT-TERM ACTION.
IT’S HOW WE KEEP FAMILIES
SAFELY IN THEIR HOMES WHILE
STATES DELIVER EMERGENCY AID.
IT’S HOW WE KEEP FAMILIES, WHO
ARE STARTING TO RECOVER, FROM
THE WORST ECONOMIC CRISIS OF
THEIR LIFETIMES, GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET.
MILLIONS OF JOBS LOST.
GRIFF: ELIZABETH WARREN TALKING
ABOUT THE EXPIRATION TODAY OF
THE FEDERAL BAN ON EVICTIONS
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
CONGRESSMAN, I’M GOING TO BRING
YOU BACK IN, YOUR THOUGHTS ON
REALLY, WHERE WE ARE IN RESPECT
TO BOTH THOSE EVICTIONS AND THE
LARGER PICTURE YOU HAVE IN YOUR
STATE, AN OUTBREAK OF THIS
DEALT AT THAT VARIANT SPIKE.
>> AS THE SENATOR SAID,
CONGRESS HAS APPROVED TENS OF
BILLIONS IN TENANT AND LANDLORD
RELIEF.
I’M ALREADY IN CONTACT WITH
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN DISBURSE THOSE
FUNDS FAIRLY TO PREVENT UNJUST
EVICTIONS.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT TO
GROUND OURSELVES WHY ARE WE IN
THIS SITUATION?
THE FIRST WAVE OF COVID WAS A
SURPRISE, THE SECOND WAVE WAS
SEASONAL, THE THIRD WAS
GEOGRAPHIC, THIS FOURTH WAVE,
THIS IS A CHOICE, THIS IS A
CHASE THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
MAKING.
THEY’RE SUING SPEAKER PELOSI
OVER MASK MANDATES AND SCIENCE.
INSTEAD OF DIRECTLY TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS, THIS VACCINE IS
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
GET A VACCINE TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AND THE ONES THAT YOU
LOVE.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN, WE’VE SEEN
MANY--
MOST OF THE NOTABLE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS LIKE STEVE SCALISE AND
OTHERS SAYING VACCINES WORK, I
GOT A VACCINE, GET A VACCINE.
BUT YOU HAVE THIS FIGHT GOING
ON, A LINE DRAWN IN THE SAND
OVER HOUSE REPUBLICANS OVER
WEARING MASKS, SAYING THAT
SPEAKER PELOSI IS ENGAGING IN
WHAT APPEARS TO BE A POWER
GRAB.
IN FACT, JUST IN THE LAST SHOW
ON CAVUTO LIVE, CHARLES PAYNE
WAS TALKING TO CONGRESSWOMAN
NANCY MACE AND SHE HAD A VIDEO
WHERE SHE BASICALLY SAID COME
AND MIKE MAKE ME DO IT.
I’M NOT GOING TO PUT THE MASK
ON.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO REPUBLICANS
THAT ARE DRAWING THE LINE IN
THE SAND?
>> SPEAKER PELOSI, LEADER
SCHUMER ARE LISTENING TO
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS.
WE ARE IN THIS SITUATION, WE
ARE FACED WITH A SERIES OF
FRUSTRATING OPTIONS BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT DOING WHAT WE KNOW
WORKS AND TAKING THE VERY BEST
OPTION, WHICH IS TO PREVENT
OUTBREAKS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I HEARD YOUR PREVIOUS GUEST, HE
WAS TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
C.D.C.’S PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE, CLAIMING SPEAKER
PELOSI FOR MASK MANDATES.
I DIDN’T HEAR HIM TELL YOUR
VIEWERS THAT THE VACCINE IS
SAFE AND THE EFFECTIVE WAY WE
CAN GET TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE PANDEMIC.
I’M FRUSTRATED WITH MASK
MANDATES, I DON’T WANT TO WEAR
MASKS ANYMORE AND I DON’T WANT
TO GO BACK INTO LOCKDOWN.
I DON’T WANT MY KIDS TO BE
EXPOSE TODAY DELTA.
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS, IT’S THE
VACCINE.
GRIFF: AND YOU’VE MENTIONED
SOMETHING THAT IS ON A LOT OF
AMERICANS’ MINDS, THE
LOCKDOWNS.
AND SECRETARY JEAN PIERRE NOT
RULING OUT THAT LOCKDOWNS COULD
COME DOWN BECAUSE THEY’LL
LISTEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE AND
LISTEN TO THE C.D.C.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT WE COULD
BE FACING ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
>> ELECTED OFFICIALS TOP
PRIORITY NEEDS TO BE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO LEAVE EVERY OPTION
ON THE TABLE WHEN WE’RE FACED
WITH A FOURTH WAVE OF--
POTENTIALLY EVEN MORE
INFECTIOUS AND MORE FATAL
VARIANTS OF THIS VIRUS.
NOBODY WANTS LOCKDOWNS,
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT LOCKDOWNS
IS THE WORST AND LAST OPTION.
THE VERY FIRST AND BEST OPTION
IS A VACCINE TO PREVENT THESE
OUTBREAKS IN THE FIRST PLACE,
THAT NEEDS TO BE THE FOCUS.
LET’S HAVE ANOTHER GOOD DAY
LIKE WE HAD YESTERDAY, ANOTHER
MILLION SHOTS IN ARMS.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN JAKE